you and I both know that the title of
this video is a lie
I'm never gonna delete it but
nonetheless you clicked on it on the odd
chance I do delete it you get to be part
of the lucky few that gets to see this
video before it disappears into the void
and that's what we're going to talk
about today that feeling of scarcity and
specifically how people market to that
scarcity to make you look at things want
things and buy things have you ever
noticed how much advertisers talk about
limits and urgency we live the thrill of
beating the clock tiny sized soft drinks
for a dollar won't stick around long buy
one get one free it's Friday and
Saturday only October Korean now October
savings and soon now why do advertisers
do this some of you may feel that this
is merely incidental all good things
come to an end after all but that isn't
quite true companies deliberately want
to send you the message that this this
incredible deal won't be here for long
because the reason we want things the
reason we buy things often has very
little to do with the product and
everything to do with how the ad makes
us feel in selling scarcity is all about
making you and I feel like we've been
given opportunity opportunity is not the
same as being given a choice opportunity
is a choice but it has a special
component it's a time bound choice it
has to be seized it won't be there for
long it forces action you can have this
product at this specially discounted
rate but the deal ends this weekend it
forces you to say yes or no to a deal
because inaction is a choice and it may
surprise you but this is different from
our normal behavior think about when
you're in a store normally usually when
you pass up on a product you're not
actually saying no to it
you're just saying maybe later we do
this all the time
we're procrastinators by Nature and if
allowed we'll shop around for a while
because the implication with most goods
and services is that they're going to
still be there when you come back but
with limited time or limited quantity
sales the goal is to remove the option
of saying maybe later to an object it
forces actions say yes and buy it or say
no and kiss this deal goodbye forever
and this is a fundamental change and can
push you from uncertainty to buying a
product out of fear that it will be gone
if you come back later and just how
effective is this form of mark
well let's look at Amazon the largest
distributor and store in the world what
does the most successful store do when
it puts on huge sales
it puts scarcity marketing to work and
from two different angles look at this
this is not only a limited time sale and
it's not only a limited quantity sale
it's both and when it's done it's done
this one little web widget that tracks
how much of the product is moved and
tracks how much time has passed moves
product like crazy take for instance
this seller who during a four-hour
lightening sale sold over 6,000 units
when they normally would have sold four
to five hundred in a given day that's a
1,300 percent increase in sales for
taking 20% off the price and putting it
on the Lightning page or to put that in
business speak so what does consumer
psychology have to say about this
well there's reacting theory and there's
commodity Theory reactant theory
developed by jack brim says that when an
individual's freedom to engage in a
specific behavior is threatened the
threatened behavior becomes more
attractive this is why for instance when
politicians mentioned gun control
ammunition flies off the shelves because
gun owners are worried about their
future ability to buy it it's also why
this video title is so provocative
because I'm threatening to take it away
from you the other theory we're going to
explore is commodity theory this idea
developed by Brock and Frampton suggests
that goods which appear to be scarce are
considered to be more valuable this is
the idea behind diamonds which are
actually not rare at all but due to a
very tightly controlled supply have
artificially sustained a high price
point so when marketing companies tell
you that something isn't in soon they're
trying to artificially restrict the
supply to raise the value in your mind
now I think a mixture of both of these
theories come into play in shaping how
we respond to perceived scarcity but
either way scarcity plays on our ancient
impulses to take advantage of limited
resources and this idea hits
particularly close to home for me
because as some of you know I work a
sales job selling houses as my main
nine-to-five job and when we run
promotionals we do it to generate this
exact kind of feeling I've been talking
about because when people want to take
their time and mull over a decision it
can lead them to buying nothing at all
so to get a positional advantage we run
promos periodically to get the leverage
to say enough thinking it's time to make
a decision I mean you do want to take
advantage of this big sale don't you in
reality is there any reason the houses
should be less expensive that month no
but we want people to think there is
because it creates urgency our reaction
to scarcity is a powerful force in
advertising and marketing it plays on
one of our most fundamental instincts to
not miss out on opportunity and this
bias is exploited constantly by
businesses who use advertising and
marketing tactics to create artificial
scarcity so just as a rule of thumb if
you live in a developed country where
abundance is the norm rather than the
exception you can begin to safely make
the assumption that if someone is
telling you supplies are low they're
probably trying to sell you something
[Music]